okay hey everyone
uh 500k let's go
um
foreign
congrats on the 500k 1 million by the
end of the year I'm not sure about that
but uh
congratulations for the 500k subscribers
and welcome back from surgery yeah thank
you
um if you're on Twitter you might have
seen it I don't I didn't post anything
on YouTube but I just
to the hospital yesterday I was in um
surgery I I've got this disease called
Bowen's disease it's like an early form
of skin cancer and they cut out like a
big chunk of not not that big I don't
know maybe like that big
uh chunk of skin on my stomach so yeah
that was a lot of fun
yeah back from surgery
so
hey you gotta be hopeful for the one mil
that's so funny because that um
you know that recent video that I put
out that's like the amazing Japanese
convenience stores and then also the the
follow-up video where I kind of like
it's like the meta apology I kind of
like critique myself I'm like this guy's
making fun of
traditional Japanese convenience stores
is so funny because like that video is
outperforming all of my other uh videos
recently because it's really modeled
after like
the whole video is meant to be satire on
these people that they make they make
like these
YouTube videos that are directed towards
a Japanese audience when they do nothing
nothing but like uh praise Japan and
it's like
it's to the point where you can see
where you can tell that they're doing it
not because they they think it but
because the money incentive is so good
because if you just say positive things
about Japan like non-stop then like you
can get crazy views on videos and again
I was trying to like satirize that
and um it was funny because I tried to
like kind of you know model my thumbnail
after
those kind of videos there's multiple
channels that kind of do that thing but
um it's funny because when I made my
thumbnail look like that you know the
video is performing so well it's like oh
this is why those people you know make
those videos but
stopping in to say congratulations on
500k good luck on waiting for that
plaque to show up eventually I think
it's at um one million I could be wrong
but I believe it's um yeah I have the
silver play button but I think the gold
one's a million
prayers for a fast and complete recovery
thank you very much
yeah I've got um
a bunch of stitches right now
in my in my stomach so
cool
you get a plaque I don't think you get a
plaque for 500k it's just kind of like a
I don't know
I've been trying to get to 500k for a
long time now so it feels good to
finally get there
hi dogon hey how's it going um yeah it's
silver I think yeah I already have the
silver I got that at 100K halfway there
greetings from Australia do a sub-a-thon
I'm not sure what a sub A Thon for
YouTube would be but hey Dogan been
watching you for Japanese practice and
entertainment for many years now
congrats on the 500k hey thank you so
much oh I gotta post this on Twitter I
don't think I did this yet hey okay here
we go
do you bro do you like jazz
um
I don't dislike Jazz but it's um
not something that I'm particularly
passionate about
500k stream
okay
okay
congrats on 500k uh hello from Hungary
hey how's it going
hope things are going well over there
on the show
um
uh Loki love the double Dogan
oh right yeah like this I should I
should get rid of this
okay
um
congrats on the 500k hey thank you so
much have you seen the YouTube channel
YouTube uh
[Music]
um
every time I watch this I think Dogan
would love this uh I haven't maybe I'll
have to check it out thank you
uh dogen you must have found out about
tricking prior to the YouTube Bang was
it from bailang yeah yeah so I was I was
in the old screw old CR old school
tricking you know Community where it was
biling like years before YouTube this
was like 2002 2003 so yeah
foreign
[Music]
congrats congrats congrats thank you so
much everyone old screw tricking yeah I
nailed it
uh hey hi Doug hey how's it going
uh congrats on 500 people hey
hi Dogan is that a second monitor
vertical uh yes it is
so I've got like two of these LG ultra
fine monitors
foreign
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
black magic design
cinema camera
uh call
Kono is
[Music]
a
community
foreign
oh hey uh super super sub or what do you
call Top chat uh paid super common thank
you Bill Barr yeah you're a big YouTuber
now how uh about to start looking into
hiring an assistant I already have a
business partner uh JP we've been
working together for about a year and a
half at this point and uh yeah it's
going well so but uh if we ever get to
the point where it's more than the two
of us can handle then might might reach
out again oh hey another one
um
yo what up dog and
okay
let's see this
okay
uh loved watching your tutorials back in
the day yourself and Sheena
she don't say right yeah we were kind of
in that same group of like the the weebs
in the tricking Community I mean there
was a lot of people in the tricking
community community that were weebs
because again when you're into martial
arts there's just a fair number of that
a fair number of people in that
community that are into karate into
Japan into Asia in general so there was
a fair number of a fair amount of
overlap a fair number of people that
were like really into you know Naruto
Hajime no IPO and stuff like that so
yeah it's funny I haven't heard that
name in a while but yeah
brings up some good memories
[Music]
um
foreign
foreign
oh no
foreign
foreign
[Music]
foreign
foreign
[Music]
come from so um
again I used to do this thing called
martial arts tricking it's kind of like
a combination of gymnastics and break
dancing and martial arts and like
Freestyle acrobatics I was really into
it in high school and at the time there
wasn't a lot of people that were doing
it
um it was like a really small community
this was before YouTube was around so
like
when YouTube became popular
what's the best way to explain this
because martial arts at least outside of
Asia isn't that major of a sport to
begin with like you know in like in the
United States of course things like
baseball soccer
well not soccer so much baseball
basketball football they're all way way
way way more popular than martial arts
right so martial arts is kind of not
that you know popular to begin with but
then within the martial arts community
community there was a community of
people called trick tricksters trickers
martial arts triggers
and these would be people that would do
they would go to like their martial arts
sessions or like martial arts like
competitions and stuff like that
and then
like oftentimes what would happen is you
know there's like a couple like two or
three moves in like taekwondo and like
wushu and stuff like that that are very
acrobatic and they're very different
from kind of gymnastic style acrobatics
uh acrobat acrobatic moves so you know
not like a backflip but more like you
know like a butterfly twist or like you
know kind of like a backflip with a kick
in or something like that and there was
a fair number of people a small number
of people in the martial arts community
that would like go to these like
tricking or martial arts competitions
and then they would do this thing like
after their like form or whatever so
they would compete in the Martial Arts
Tournament and then like afterwards when
all the mats were still on the ground
people would like go out and try and
like one-up each other and do like um
you know butterfly Swiss or like a
backflip or something like that and
originally there was a website called
bylang.com mom and it was a place where
people would upload videos of themselves
doing this
and um
when I kind of stumbled across this one
day
so um I found some of these videos and I
was like oh this is so cool like I want
to learn it and so like I I did all the
research I could on like martial arts
tricking and like what I needed to do to
learn all this stuff and there was a
there was like a single online Forum
called Trix tutorials at the time that
basically everyone in the world that was
a trickster used and so naturally I also
signed up for you know uh I signed up on
that Forum but but at the time my real
name it was already taken someone else
had that username so I was like okay
what's my what's my username gonna be
and um
well yeah there actually are a lot of uh
capoeira moves
um that people kind of integrate into
tricking as well
um but
I was really into Zen Buddhism at the
time as well and for those that don't
know dolgin is like one of the
people that brought Zen Buddhism
specifically that kind of like
proliferated it in Japan
um there are multiple types of Zen
Buddhism but the kind he proliferated
one of them
and it's called Soto Zen yeah jujimufu
fan exactly exactly like
yeah jujimufu he ran that tricks
tutorials forum
and um yeah it brings back a lot of
memories but at the time again the name
my real name was taken and so I was like
okay I'll just go with Dogan then
because I was reading about dogen at the
time and I thought it was like an
interesting figure so
it's kind of just you know stuck since
then okay the xenome project thank you
very much for the Super Chat very much
appreciated congrats on 500k thank you
for being part of my goal to be
bilingual in my mom's native tongue as a
late bloomer 31 not there yet but it's
only five months hey
at least you're giving it your your all
I mean better late than never right and
um I'm very happy to uh hear that you
know my videos help you or maybe inspire
you in some way and thank you very much
for the Super Chat means a lot
and yeah seriously better late than
never go for it dude
okay uh hi Logan how do you deal with
social isolation in Japan
um
well I'm kind of an introvert to begin
with I mean it's kind of like
counterproductive or not
counterproductive but it's kind of a
June
um what do you say
version imagine
uh it's a inconsistency it's a contra
yeah it's kind of like a contradiction
to say I'm an introvert when I'm like
live streaming to like
300 people ish right now but um yeah
contradiction
but like I'm I'm not one I'm not like a
big party person
um I can do well with kind of just like
chilling by myself
um you know working on YouTube videos
and that kind of thing so I've never
really been one of these people that has
what would you say had trouble making
friends in Japan because I've never
really
tried to go out and make friends in
Japan
um like I would kind of naturally
organically meet like two or three
people
in my community whether it was like when
I was teaching English or like when I
used to work at Apu or whatever it might
be now that I'm a YouTuber you know I've
got like um
uh some YouTube buddies as well you know
Joey
uh carner garnt uh Chris you know a few
few guys the albaton Matt as well for
sure there's like I don't know 30 or 40
really cool YouTube people that I've met
since starting this and
um I just you know
I have a really really good what would
you say time interacting with with
everyone in that community and I don't
really what would you say uh feel the
need to
again I'm not like a terribly social
person to begin with so I'm really happy
with the community that have very been
very fortunate to be a a part of and
I don't really go out like drinking and
stuff like that usually so just like you
know in in bepu or whatever so
um
yeah I don't really deal with the social
isolation too much probably spent too
much time on that question anyway uh
sorry for not being able to help more
um
Percival cool I was on the fence on
buying a PS4 to play bloodborne and you
told me to just go for it I bought it
and I am six trophies away from the
Platinum now thanks Dogan hey nice yeah
bloodborne such a good game seriously oh
my god there there have been
I've told the story so many times at
this point but I used to be really
really into video games like hardcore
gamer when I was in like Middle School
and I played a bunch of like all the
popular video games at the time you know
like I had like a PS2 and
um before that I had an N64 obviously
like you know like Zelda 64 Ocarina of
Time and
um you know Smash Brothers the original
all those games but then the first game
that I ever played that like had a
profound impact on my life was the
original Final Fantasy VII like I've
played a bunch of video games that I
kind of think in retrospect like I
probably spent too much time on that and
I could have been using my time in a
more productive way but there are three
games in my life that I've played where
I thought
I not only do I not regret spending any
time playing those games but I think
playing those games enhanced my life in
such an incredible way that like I
wouldn't change it for anything and the
games and those three games are the
original Final Fantasy VII
jet grind radio the original for
Dreamcast and then bloodborne for PS4
all these are just like
oh my God like incredible incredible
games
just you can learn so much just about
like I don't know life and art from
these these these games
do you live a Zen Buddhist lifestyle
still uh no I do not but I used to I
used to be really into that and I used
to like do zazen like sitting meditation
and stuff like that so
uh Final Fantasy VII impacted many of my
friends as well yeah man that best scam
best game
shout out for jet grind radio seriously
bloodborne is a game that I started a
lot of the times uh and can't seem to
get it yeah for me did I get both of
those comments
hey have this uh I didn't get that
uh Raphael thank you so much
that's is that Thai Bots
I think that's what that is but thank
you very much very much appreciate the
super chat
um
cheers appreciate it dude or uh do this
not sure thank you very much
um let's see was it difficult to buy a
house in Japan as a foreigner yes it was
actually a nightmare it was a nightmare
and I'm actually like not even like
supposed to really get into the details
so much because we had so much trouble
with the bank
but that's I don't know it's kind of
less because I'm a foreigner and more
because of the place that we bought like
are the land itself but the fact that
I'm a foreigner played into that a
little bit but if you have permanent
residency I did not have it at the time
um then it's not that big of a deal it
was kind of a combination of things for
me it was like I didn't have permanent
residency I was a full-time YouTuber
and then we also had a little like there
were some issues on the land itself and
the bank was like oh this is kind of
like sketchy for us to not sketchy
they're kind of like we can't
we don't know if the value of this land
is going to be high in like 10 or 15
years or whatever so
it's a little bit hard for us to like
give you a loan but that's not what they
told us originally and that's like where
things went downhill basically anyway I
won't get into that that story right now
good morning from Oita hey how's it
going thank you very much
foreign
[Music]
foreign
correct my Japanese if you have the time
uh sure
against
uh what's like the more natural way to
say that
maybe it would be more natural to say
like it's
like
this there there aren't any what would
you say like obvious errors in this
Japanese there are no blatant errors in
your Japanese but it's also kind of like
it sounds like
English that has been translated into
Japanese rather than like Japanese that
was constructed from the ground up
in Japanese to begin with so again I'll
type in the chat like what what maybe
the more natural way to say it it's
um
maybe maybe like that
um yeah and dolga might is probably a
better way to say it I'm hoping you
recover from surgery quickly wishing you
well from Florida well thank you very
much
appreciate that yeah it's uh again I've
got like a big cut on my stomach right
now and a bunch of stitches but uh it
wasn't I mean too bad it made for a good
tweet though
okay let's see
uh cool cool thanks so much hey no
problem thank you very much for uh the
comment after years in Japan do you
prefer the Japanese keyboard or the
English keyboard I hate the Japanese
keyboard I can't stand it
um
I am much more I'm much faster on an
English keyboard on an American keyboard
but on top of that like there are so
many in my opinion buttons that you
don't need on a Japanese keyboard like
there's a button specifically for um
like changing from English into Japanese
and vice versa but like you can just
like program like a keyboard shortcut
for that and in in putting all these
extra buttons in a Japanese keyboard it
makes
um each button not each button but many
of the buttons on a on on the Japanese
keyboard much smaller than they are on
an American keyboard so like if I start
typing on the Japanese keyboard I start
hitting all these buttons that uh
actually do different things they're not
actually letters because I'm so used to
using like a American keyboard so
um
okay
did I answer that I'm okay wishing you
well from Florida yeah
appreciate it and hope uh hope you
weren't hit by that hurricane too bad
heard it was real bad down there
um
hello long time no see hey how's it
going dogen I found out you were uh my
cousin Evan's roommate in college so
that's cool hey yeah Evan I love that
dude super cool dude
I I got along with him really really
well he was an awesome dude
um
okay let's see will you be on trash
taste podcast with Joni uh Joey garnt
and Connor love your work congrats on
500.
um yeah I'd love to I mean they're
obviously on their um American tour
right now and they're killing it I'm you
know super happy for them and my
daughters are a little bit older now and
I've been able to travel a little bit
more recently so um if they're still
down yeah I'd love to be on their
podcast I love their podcast I was
watching it in the hospital yesterday
actually
foreign
okay
small world huh yeah I mean Julie
invited me a long time ago but
um
it was like right after my daughter not
right after my daughters were born but
it was at a time where I couldn't really
get out of the house so much so
yeah hopefully we can make it happen
soon
foreign
G test today I'm horrendous at kanji so
I'm pretty elated hey nice nice work
um I would say that the unfortunate
thing is that
there's a high probability that all the
time that you spend learning kanji will
become irrelevant
and that's because like
they're
loan words are replacing Japanese like
or not Japanese like kanji at this rate
so fast that it's like it's almost I
don't think it's pointless at all
but um
yeah it's
you used to get a really good bang for
your buck when you studied kanji like 20
30 years ago but like these days it's
like you study the kanji and then it's
like you go watch like a Japanese TV
show and you're like wait they're not
even like saying the Japanese word
they're just saying like the loan word
so
like people don't even really say like
like which means International they just
say good old
that's a really good example
hey
okay
Logan do you write your o's clockwise or
counterclockwise
um
I guess counterclockwise yeah sorry for
being a hikomori but what happened to
you you have stitches can you give a
quick rundown on what happened I hope
you're okay now yeah sure um give me a
second I'm gonna lower my my desk I
gotta do this slowly it always like free
um glitches out
okay
Okay so
oh I cannot move quickly right now
foreign
yeah so um
this might be a good like just story to
tell for a lot of people that don't take
care of themselves like like I used to I
didn't take care of myself for a long
time in terms of health but like I had a
it kind of looks like a mole I think it
started out as a mole
um
and it was on my stomach and it started
getting like a little bit bigger
like I noticed like oh this is like this
looks like a little bit larger than a
normal mole and so like I went to a
dermatologist and I was like is this
like dangerous do you think this could
be like skin cancer and they were like
oh no no no like you're gonna be like
don't worry about it you're fine and I
was like
okay
um I guess if you say so then I'll take
you all you know you're the expert so I
didn't really think too much about it uh
but then it started getting like bigger
and bigger and bigger and I went back to
another dermatologist like a year later
because I was like this is like not only
getting like bigger but it's starting to
get like um kind of like not just like
like a like a brownish mole or whatever
you know something more like
uh coal
like red and kind of like flaky I was
like is this normal and they were like
that's probably fine like just put like
this medicine on it and you'll be fine
and I was like okay and then
it just kept growing and I was like I
can't touch oh hey Angela how's it going
thank you for for uh stopping in
appreciate it uh thank you for the kind
words good to be home
um but then I was like I can't trust
this dermatologist like he's not really
taking me seriously so I went to a
different dermatologist and he said the
exact same thing he was like you're
probably fine I was like okay
um are you sure and he was like well if
you're like really like uh concerned we
could like you know take a sample and
like send it to the lab to see if it's
like dangerous I was like yeah let's do
that and he was like okay
and so we did it and then like uh the
results came back and it's this disease
called Bowen's disease it's basically
like um
it's kind of like a form of skin cancer
it's not like as dangerous as you know
proper skin cancer but it it often
morphs into proper skin cancer which can
be very dangerous because that can
spread throughout the rest of the body
so
um it was so funny because I was like
yeah um it would have been really great
like if we could have done this test a
long time ago when when this was like
half the size that it was but now it's
like you know
a lot it had become much bigger over the
course of like two years and they were
like oh yeah like we can't fix this with
like you know like cream or anything
like that but like we have to physically
like cut out the entire skin in that
area I was like okay great so that's how
I was in the hospital the other day but
the reason I kind of wanted to tell the
story is because
um
yeah you this is really the thing you
are your own best Advocate and so like
if you have something whether it's like
you know a skin issue or whatever it
might be that you think is a little bit
suspicious don't
sleep on it get you know address it as
soon as you can first figure out if it's
in fact dangerous or not because it's
better safe than sorry like I wouldn't
have had to go to the hospital and spend
a bunch of money and like you know
underground undergone surgery and have
like part of my you know abdomen skin
cut out if we had caught this a lot
earlier but like none of the doctors
that saw me for those first couple years
would really take me seriously like I
had to push back hard and be like hey I
don't like let's
can you please take a sample I I this is
clearly not just like a normal mole and
they were like
oh sorry let me let me block this spam
um
okay
and so yeah finally like I found a
proper a good doctor that would like
listen to me and he was like Yep this is
dangerous we got to take care of this we
got to cut it out and so that's what I
was in for
um
okay
hatsunami
hatsumi misuru hatsumini
um
okay so I think what this person is uh
saying is like how do you deal with
Japanese
um that's not standard Tokyo dialect
like what do you
isn't it hard to understand and
um
I think that there are like maybe like
two or three dialects in Japan where you
really have have to like spend some time
understanding the dialect before you can
understand it one of those is I think
it's called
foreign
like Northeastern Japan they've got like
a real strong dialect
um yeah it's about event and then the
other one is a doll
yeah so like uh in Kyushu
this is actually I don't know if this is
100 true or not but it's my
understanding that you know like the
movie The Last Samurai like
um
Tom Cruise kind of like allies himself
with the Japanese town that is trying to
fight off like the westernization of
Japan
um and I believe I think I'm getting
this right it might not be though um
that
the character that Watanabe Kang is
supposed to be modeled after is this guy
that was down in kagoshima and
they
I don't know if it was originally very
different or not or like they
intentionally changed the dialect to
make it even harder to understand but
like
oh hey Rafi how's it going thank you
very much
um anyway long story short during that
fight between like you know the
the people who wanted to
globalize Japan and then the people that
were against that back in you know the
major restoration and like 1868
um there was a lot of people on the
on the side that was trying to you know
push Japan into more of like a global
global environment that had a lot of
trouble because they couldn't understand
the Japanese of the other of the people
that they were fighting because
kagoshima Beng is that sorry let me take
care of that bot again
um a hide user on this channel
hopefully we got that anyway conquestima
Bend is really really hard to understand
it's kind of like similar to how I
believe they used like Native American
um
language
to I forget what you say uh
angle angle
yeah it's like uh
so create like coded messages such that
the enemy can't understand it they kind
of the same thing kind of happened
during that uh battle back in the Meiji
restoration
foreign
they were the code talkers yeah
I've heard Hiroshima Ben is also very
hard to understand but not quite as hard
as you know
um Last Samurai
foreign
foreign
's character is supposed to be based off
of him I believe
and let's see uh
yeah born in kagoshima
um
artworks depicting
okay uh the last yeah there's a link at
the end of
uh saigo takamori's uh like Wikipedia
page that links to The Last Samurai so
yeah I'm pretty sure that the Last
Samurai yeah it was supposed to be based
off of him
foreign
how did you come by and learn Japanese
interested as a half British hope you
recover well
foreign
foreign
foreign
so I can't say where my house is
uh for obvious reasons but um I do live
in Bedford okay uh congrats on 500k I
want to ask you about your take on
writing do you off do you write a do you
write often on a regular basis how does
how long does it take you to write a
video thanks for the great content
um
thank you for the question I like this
question um for those that don't know I
actually come from
kind of a writing background
and what I mean by that is I wanted to
become a writer immediately after
graduate even before graduating from
from University I actually have the
pleasure the privilege of meeting the
main singer of a Japanese band that I
was really really into when I was in um
High School it was actually the band
that inspired me to learn Japanese and
so meeting her was like a life-changing
experience and it was like I was asking
her like why is she wanting to become a
singer and stuff like that and to make a
very long story short she was like
my my older brother or my brother is a
salaryman and like my
um
my sister is an ol I think that's like
for those that don't know oh Ella is
kind of like a
it's
like
a
some people might not agree with this
translation but kind of like someone
that has a secretarial role in an office
it's oftentimes traditionally speaking
it's female workers in the office in
Japanese offices that will do things
like organizing uh or like preparing
documents organized or preparing tea for
guests and stuff like that it's
obviously things are changing now and
there are less ol Japan's still got you
know a long way to go but
um the singer basically said you know
I've got two siblings that are basically
following that straight path and you
know they uh or that traditional path
like kind of proper job in society but
um I always wanted to do something that
I hoped like would impact people and I
left this bit out of the story I forgot
but I wrote them a letter when I started
studying abroad and I was like
um you don't know who I am but um I
started studying Japanese specifically
because of your music and I'm in Japan
now like
seven eight years later and I'm so happy
and I just wanted to reach out and say
thank you and it was like it's actually
pretty long letter
and um but there were they were a small
band and so they sent me a a song or a
message back and they're like hey come
out to the next like uh concert and like
we'd love to talk with you and I was
like wait what and so again I had the
very unique opportunity of uh going out
to
meet them and you know speak with them
and speak with the main singer and um
she literally said to me like again like
my sister and my brother they've they're
not in a position where like financially
speaking they would ever be in trouble
you know but they would also never get
the kind of letter that you wrote me and
that's you know like that's why I do
what I do like I want to like inspire
people and I want to like um you know
try and move people and like make a
difference with music and I was like
yeah like oh my God like yes seriously
and
um that resonated with me so much and I
was like that's what I want to do too
but I don't have any musical talent and
so I was like well what can I do and so
when she said like you know that letter
that you you wrote it really meant so
much to me and I was like
maybe I should try like writing
and at this point I had been writing on
on a Blog for I don't know two or three
years at this point just like a tricking
blog that I had
and I was like I should you know I'm
gonna lean into this a little bit more
and I took writing a little bit more
seriously in my last two years last year
of University I took a bunch of courses
on creative writing and then the entire
time that I was doing the jet program
like the three years
um
I
I would basically just go teach English
at school during the day and then I
would go back to my apartment in Japan
and like alone in my apartment and I
would just write right right right right
and I spent three years doing that
basically and I didn't really go out
that much at the time but I kind of I
like to think that I developed my riding
chops I became okay at writing during
that time and many of the scripts that I
actually ended up creating for YouTube
or or many of the YouTube videos that
some of you may have seen I actually
wrote like 10 years prior not 10 like
five or six years prior when I was on
the jet program so like three or four
examples would be like the butter script
I wrote that when I was on the jet
program I didn't turn it into a video
until three or four years later same
thing with like the um
uh
the supermarket video that's another one
there's a video called
um Oblivion that's another one
um
I don't know there's like probably 10
videos I just can't think of any more
off the top of my head but um
I in that sense I come from a writing
background and I actually have like two
or three
um short stories that are available on
Amazon
um in Japanese and you know I
I self-publish them they uh
I didn't really get that much money from
them but they got
um an okay response from the people that
uh read them and so
again I kind of just became a YouTuber
because it allowed me to keep on writing
um I knew that I'd be able to make more
money doing YouTube than I was writing
because I was confident my writing
abilities and I was like you know I bet
if I just took this same exact script
but then turned it into a video it would
do a lot better like more people would
see it and that's kind of I've just been
running with that since then so
um but I think the question was like how
long does it take you to script a video
it really depends on the video but um I
say generally speaking four days
four days
for a typical video that's like three or
four minutes long
um and someone else said would you
consider yourself good at writing I
don't necessarily think that I'm good at
writing I think I can I think I know the
basics of writing
and I think that I can
[Music]
um
recognize
bad writing if that makes sense
would another example uh of what you
mentioned also be kisate because I was
informed it's more natural to say coffee
yeah
uh kind of are
they have kind of like a slightly
different Nuance to them but somewhat
yes
and the main thing with writing this is
kind of just like my philosophy it's um
the single best thing you can do
is just
edit the things that you've written and
what I mean by that is
if you have like an I do this for
everything that any anything that I do
whether it's on YouTube or on Twitter
it's like you have
an idea it's like oh that's a funny idea
right I think the overwhelming majority
of people they'll take the funny idea
and they'll immediately spit it out
um you know
as they thought it on Twitter or on
YouTube or whatever it might be and then
you know just hit the share button
um but if you just you know
take a little bit of time and kind of
like
sit down and think critically about
about the words that create the thought
you can nine times out of ten ten times
out of ten turn that into a much much
much funnier
uh not necessarily funnier but polished
and interesting
packet so to speak and so like here's a
good example
um
recently I had a tweet
um
what was it a door
I want to get read it as I wrote it um
Japan's greatest tragedy is having the
world's best toilets and no Mexican food
and then what's the point of owning a
Ferrari if you never take it to a track
um that did you know pretty well got
like
18
000 retweets I think it was on like
Reddit and stuff like that um but that's
like exact I spent I did the exact same
thing with that tweet like the I had
always had the thought in my mind it's
like
Japan has the best toilets and not the
best Mexican but no Mexican food
um that's a shame right
and when you just you know read it the
Tweet you kind of I don't know most
people would assume that it's like oh he
just you know had this idea or whatever
and wrote it down and then published it
but I I spent like three days
editing or not editing but revising that
like I didn't spend a full three days it
was it was much more like um
I spent time each day over the course of
like three or four days
so I spent like you know 15 minutes each
of those days and I was like okay
is this the correct word order so again
like if I go back to that um
Japan's greatest tragedy is having the
world's best toilets and no Mexican food
um
I had originally written this is
Japan's greatest tragedy
is that it has the world's best toilets
but no Mexican food
but it was a little bit too clunky so to
speak
again Japan's greatest tragedy is that
it has the world's best toilets but no
Mexican food takes a little bit too too
long to read it doesn't come off the it
doesn't come off your tongue as quickly
so I was like I need to edit this I need
to make it quicker and snappier and
easier to understand so rather rather
than saying Japan's greatest tragedy is
that it has the world's best toilets I
said Japan's greatest tragedy is having
the world's best toilets and no Mexican
food and I did the exact same thing with
uh you know the follow-up sentence with
which is what's the point of owning a
Ferrari if you never take it to the
track you know I originally thought
maybe should it be Ferrari should it be
Supercar should it be like Nissan GTR
and I thought about like all of the the
different nuances and like okay supercar
is good it makes for a good joke but
Ferrari is even more specific so it's
funnier but like
would it be funnier even even
funnier if it was like if it was a
Nissan GTR because that's that's a
Japanese car right but then I was like
but not as many people know what a
Nissan GTR is compared to a Ferrari
right and so you know there are just
like so many little things that every
single word
and again I don't think I'm I'm a
particularly good writer this is just
what I do
um this is how I like I I write things
um
I just
I edit and I re-edit and I re-edit and I
re-edit and I re-edit until I think that
it's uh until I think that I can't
improve it anymore and I think that
anyone that wants to get into writing if
you just take a little bit of time and
kind of practice with that that's like
the number one advice that I can give
people is
um
you know
edit edit your thoughts if you that's
like the single best thing you can do
take time to edit and think about every
word in each sentence think about the
sentence order think about the word
order think about the paragraph order
everything can be a little bit more
polished usually
thank you very much
very much appreciated
and also
k550 uh 480 Yen thank you very much
and a waving lemon
my other half of Super Chat is
foreign
America America
yeah so
for those that don't know I recently
built a house here and uh in Pepper and
this is Brandon Japan get for 480. 480
Yen that's like a Dollar Tree it's so
sad because it's true the inflation rate
or not the exchange rate is just like
killing Japan right now it's crazy it's
145 Yen to the dollar right now it's
insane like I converted uh 250 US
dollars to Yen earlier today and it was
like 250 became like 360 or not 360 but
like uh
it's just like it's crazy uh the
exchange rate
um but yeah I live in Beppo has the
highest concentration of Onsen in Japan
and um because of that if you build a
house in Beppo it's actually fairly easy
to get an Onsen in your house but I
tried to make a comedic video about this
recently but it's funny because we put
an Onsen in our house I spent a bunch of
extra money and you know it wasn't I
think it was like 5 000 extra dollars to
set up the Onsen
um so it wasn't like an exorbitant
amount of money especially considering
there are so many people that will spend
like I don't know two thousand dollars
just to go on a trip like an Onsen trip
in Japan and so you know I'm really glad
that we did it but it's funny because
like at the end of the day most nine
times out of ten it's like I don't have
time to like get in the bath I need to
get to bed like because I was like
reading to my daughters or you know I
was up late editing or whatever it's
like I have an Onsen in my house and
it's like I hardly hardly ever use it
and not now I can't even get in it if I
wanted to because I recently had surgery
you know so I've got um
like all these stitches on my stomach I
can't even take a bath so
hey Dogan uh I asked you a question at
your Osaka show about raising bilingual
children thank you for the book
recommendation is there a way to
re-watch your Osaka Show online hey I
remember you um thank you very much for
coming to the show and thank you very
much for the Super Chat as well wow
thank you so much I hope that the book
um I I don't know if you got it or not
but I uh I was reading it to my kids
earlier today again it's a fantastic
fantastic book and
um unfortunately at this point there is
no longer any way to re-watch the Osaka
Show online there was for a little bit
of time you could re-watch using the
links that I had shared on different
platforms but um it they had a rule
where the link was only going to be live
for two weeks and so it's unfortunately
no longer live but again thank you very
much for coming out to the show and um
if you haven't bought that book already
I bought the book the same day nice nice
yeah it's such a good book it's such a
good book
sweet I can't wait for two response to
overcharge uh oblivious tourists this
coming winter uh holiday season that's
the funny thing though it's like the
Japan the Japanese yen is so weak right
now I think that if tourist spots even
if they overcharge tourists tourists
will just think that that's the normal
price in Japan
because
the the yen is that weak right now it's
crazy they'll just be like oh yeah
that's like a reasonable price
um now would be a good time to insert
ads creators earn more money inserting
ads uh and more stream more viewers are
watching give it a try
maybe we'll wait a little bit more I
should probably try that in I don't know
like five or ten minutes I've never
tried that fun I'm curious to try it but
okay what is the name of the book about
bilingual kids please share the name
with us yeah so it's called um
uh let's see
how to teach your child to read in 100
easy lessons
is like the single best book that you
can in my understanding
um that you can use to teach
your child how to read how about that
um yeah and I've been using it with my
kids and it's by the time you get to the
end of the book your kids are supposed
to be able to read at a second an
elementary uh
Elementary School second grade level
um like in the United States at that
level
um and it's really crazy because like my
kids are they just turned five so
they're not even close to being at like
in second grade and you know uh
Elementary School that they're like
they've got like two or three years but
they can already read like a fair amount
like um
let me see if I can remember the exact
words in the story there was like a
story
a cow is sitting on a hot gate the cow
said
ow this gate is hot
I don't like hot Gates
I will go now or something like that you
know very very very simple English but
like even in the United States like
most five-year-olds
have
um don't start reading haven't really
properly started reading unless um their
parents have taken a lot of additional
time to
what is a hot gate you know it's like a
gate for uh like where the cow the cow's
pen or whatever or whatever
um anyway
it's um it's remarkable how well that
book works it's really fantastic okay
YouTubers
foreign
[Music]
sounds like a YouTube channel are you a
YouTuber
um
I was four when I noticed I could read
Jesus
high IQ in the chat hey
um I didn't start reading until I was
after five so like my kids are already
better at reading
um
at their age than I was when I was their
age so
um but you have to put in the additional
effort like I always say this whenever I
talk about this but like people like
Joey or or garnt as well um you know
they're bilingual
um Joey's speaks you know like properly
bilingual
um unlike me I'm not you know even close
to like where Joey is or
um I I obviously can't really talk about
garn's
language ability because I don't know
anything about Thai but it's my
understanding that he's completely
bilingual as well and the thing that
they've both talked about is like their
parents were not necessarily very strict
about it
um
but they they put in like the extra
hours so to speak like their moms would
only speak to them in the one language
like Japanese or Thai
and um
and like if they're if the kids tried to
speak it to them in like English the the
parents wouldn't even respond such that
it would force them to speak the the
second language right and uh again like
it's from the child's perspective it's a
little bit like mean so to speak it's
like hey like I know you understand me
why aren't you responding but at the
same time I think it actually is the
right decision because it's remarkable
how easy it is
for your kids to stop practicing that
second language when they know that you
understand it as well so like
I really really really try really hard
to um
uh
it's you know only speak English with my
kids but then also read to them a lot
make sure that
um
at least a fair amount of the media that
they consume is English media etc etc
but you know again it's like it's a
misconception that people like
um again like Joey and Gart never put in
like the additional effort like you have
to put in the additional effort to get
that good at uh two languages even if
you're brought up in a bilingual
household there are so many people that
are brought up in a bilingual household
that when they speak you what would you
say they sound completely
yeah they front loaded the effort
exactly it sounds they sound native but
then like when they start writing things
down
and I'm not talking about Joey and gar
I'm speaking about other people that are
brought up in a bilingual environment
but then didn't put in the additional
effort on the side
um
you can often immediately recognize that
they're not nearly as good at their
second language when you see that when
you see their writing
so I've been watching your skits for
years now so thank you very uh so thank
you for the very random but always
entertaining content
Arigato I don't like hot Gates I won't
go now hey that's a great comment thank
you very much mistakon and then also me
um
[Music]
foreign
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
my advice for study abroad is kind of
like the same thing I was just talking
about like it's really hard to do but
if you're serious about learning
Japanese
don't hang out with the other exchange
students
um like you again you always have to put
in the additional effort like all the
people
that in we're all in the same program as
me on study abroad they were kind of
like two groups
one group that was like studying abroad
in Japan because they were kind of like
into Japan a little bit and they wanted
to you know take a year abroad somewhere
but then
um they weren't like super super serious
about learning Japanese but then there
was another group that was like they
were there because they wanted to learn
Japanese and like all the people in the
first group basically stayed within that
kind of you know study abroad bubble and
um you know they lived in the dorm with
all the other exchange students and they
would take the trains to the school with
their exchange student with you know
their their buddies from the dorm and
it would it was funny because and I used
to be in that group because
um I I changed to a study of a Homestay
program like halfway through but it's
just it's so easy to again use English
in that setting just because it's the
natural thing to do right and like I met
so many great people and I made so many
great friendships on the job and when I
was studying abroad in Japan like Roger
Swann being one of them for those that
don't know Roger Swann was like one of
the original
j-vloggers he very very tragically
passed away
um about 10 years ago at this point
maybe 11 at this point but uh
he would make these videos about
studying abroad in Japan and
um
and he would make like these reviews of
like Japanese horror movies like
audition and like Ichi the Killer and
stuff like that and he lived right next
to me in the dorm and it was funny
because we were both like J vloggers
kind of
and um
I had a wonderful wonderful friendship
with him he was he was such a great guy
but I made kind of like the not
executive decision but I was like I'm
I'm here to
study Japanese and so despite the fact
that I have all these great friends that
I'm you know living with and having a
great time with
I need to move out of the storm and I
need to do a Homestay because I'm going
to get a lot more job and I'm going to
get a lot better at Japanese if um if I
do that so
that's what I did and I think that my
Japanese improved significantly because
of that but again it's it all kind of
depends on your goals
um if you're not like super hardcore
then that's totally fine to you know
what would you say uh
different people prioritize prioritize
different things some people get more
out of you know the social interactions
and whether that's with the social with
the study abroad students or whether
that was you know whether that's with
the Japanese students or whatever
um you know my buddy Matt versus Japan
has got this really funny story like he
was doing a Homestay in his original
um study abroad program but like he was
so into he was so hardcore studying that
like he would like stay in his room and
study flash cards rather than like just
going out and like uh going like
exploring Japan on the weekends with
them
it's such a funny
um what would you say like
situation
but yeah Matt's Matt's got incredible
Japanese so
um better than mine uh Angela thank you
so much uh 10 euros I'm so happy you're
out of the hospital uh that I forgot to
congratulate you for the 500k
um
for those that don't know Angela has
been one of my
long has been a fan of mine for a really
long time now she's been super
supportive of me and she's also one of
my moderators on Twitch so I normally
don't stream on YouTube Just because
um to be frank I think it kind of
dilutes my comedic content I think a lot
of people don't want to see
this I want to say I think they want to
see the jokes
um so but I do enjoy streaming so I
stream maybe like once a week or so on
on Twitch and um
Angela's been a great help there Angela
thank you very much for all the support
over the years really appreciate it
okay uh and also Randall random Randall
is that you maybe I'm not sure you said
something about the low ceiling in your
upstairs room means it doesn't count as
a regular bedroom can you elaborate it's
too high to be a 1.4 meter Loft just
bought land in Olas yeah
[Music]
can be
your security
anyway uh campaign it's I think that's
the right anyway
um it's too high to be 1.4 Loft yeah I
think I misspoke in that video um we
have the storage space and that is it it
is it does follow the uh
what would you say the regulation in the
sense that it's less than 1.4 meters
high and I was getting the two things
confused in my head so like the storage
space is below 1.4 meters high the
ceiling in there so it doesn't count as
a room but the uh The Loft it's just um
I believe that it does count as a normal
room
but
actually no no no
I think that it's not a normal room but
also not a loft either I think it's
something else entirely but I can't
remember what it is
but um
they were oops
there was there was some reason that we
had to get to keep the ceiling in there
fairly low
uh can you drop your Twitch link I
assume it's also under Dugan yeah so
it's just twitch.com
just like you know my Twitter or my
YouTube or whatever it might be
um
[Music]
this is foreign
versus Japan now that he's in Japan are
you going to do an in-person collab yep
absolutely for sure
um
yeah and we've already met up once I
mentioned that earlier but yeah that was
really cool finally meeting him
hmm
this is
foreign
it might be more natural in this
circumstance to say saichu or tochu
um anyway my advice would be
spend a lot of time on the land
um I think that for our house
the house itself turned out incredible
like I couldn't be happier with the
house that we have here but we we kind
of rushed into it because we went to the
model house and we were so impressed by
it and we fell in love with it so
quickly
that um
we
didn't spend enough time researching the
land that we bought and we didn't learn
about all these problems that the land
had until we had already started
building on the land and so the one
piece of advice that I I would really
really push for is if you're still in
the phase where you haven't decided on
the land spend a long time on that
I think there's a fair amount of things
that you can kind of like change about
the house as you're building but it's
like
once you buy the land it's hard to you
know
get out of that so spend a lot of time
on that make sure make sure you're
building it in the right place make sure
that the water is good that you know
the the streets are good and everything
is like taken care of and
um it's not like a privately owned Road
or anything like that because that'll
screw up like whether or not the bank
will give you money that's what happened
to us so
on YouTube
foreign
foreign
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
oh hey okay Louie DC thank you very much
for the uh Super Chat one piece I think
that's the yeah Luffy I just watched my
buddies um
my buddy Manu
for those that don't know German
YouTuber super cool dude
um living in Japan as well he was one of
the guys that came out to my house like
Reveal video he's got his his entire
channel is dedicated to one piece but
it's so funny because I've never been
able to watch one of his videos because
he blocks his channel from being able to
be viewed in Japan because
um
Japanese
um publishing agencies and like anime
companies they're really strict about
like the uh
um
call copyright laws and stuff like that
he doesn't want to get like any channel
strikes so I hadn't seen any of his
videos until recently but he shared this
video like why you should watch One
Piece and I watched it when I was in the
hospital and I was like
I should watch One Piece it was such a
good video but anyway thank you very
much I'm going to Machida for a study
abroad March through July and I'm
worried about making Japanese friends
since I'm not super outgoing do you have
any specific tips
um I kind of talked about this earlier
but I'm not very outgoing as well so
it's kind of hard for me to give advice
but
like it really kind of depends on
what kind of friends you want I think
the best thing that you can do
is if you have a hobby that you're
something that like you're really into
try and make Japanese friends that have
that hobby don't try and make friends
that are in like don't try and make
Japanese friends that are like part of
that that universities like
International Club because nine times
out of ten those students will have like
just gotten back from study abroad in
the United States or like somewhere else
and the reason that they're in that club
is because they want to find a foreigner
friend that they can speak English to
whereas like if you can make a friend
with someone on like you know the break
dancing Circle or the break dancing club
or whatever then there's a high
probability that they don't even speak
any English to begin with and so
that's what I did again when I was
studying abroad like there was these two
groups um
these two well there was one club at the
school that was like the international
uh club and like there was a bunch of
Japanese students in it and that they
all joined it because they wanted to
make foreign friends and they all spoke
English to the foreign friends right
um and when I was in that club I was
like this isn't like going well for me
like if anything like I'm being like
taken advantage of
and so I was like I gotta like find like
a new group of friends and so like I
started doing uh tricking martial arts
tricking that acrobat you know acrobatic
sport I used to do I made some friends
that were part of like again kind of
like the dance team at Ko University and
they didn't speak any English at all so
that worked out really well
um hopefully hopefully you can find some
people that share your hobbies as well
okay uh Asian Boston is
foreign
[Music]
you are
because
yoga
foreign
foreign
foreign
[Music]
imagining
because
okay
okay
uh Randall hey how's it going man thank
you so much
any suggestions for sources to get
exposure to Native speech on the web
streamers podcasts um I think
I would actually recommend Japanese real
life movies
um the movie that I mentioned earlier
uh 12 kind Japanese people
I've never found a movie that's better
than this and the reason for this is
because this is a courtroom drama and it
all takes place in one room and it's
nothing but Japanese people talking
for two hours there's no point in the
movie where people aren't talking in
Japanese it's nothing but talking and so
in that sense it's really really really
really good and it's also great because
you can kind of hear different levels of
Japanese as the movie progresses like at
the beginning of the movie none of the
people in the movie
uh none of the people in the room know
each other so they're using like really
polite Japanese to each other but then
like as the movie progresses and the
characters get more comfortable with
each other some of the characters start
using more relaxed Japanese so there's a
it's um you get exposure to different
kinds of Japanese as well the only
potential downside is that it um
it's a little bit old like I think it
came out in like the 80s
maybe even like the late probably 80s I
think it was the 80s and so in that
sense there aren't nearly as many like
loan Words which I think is a good thing
but to be frank
um there are many words that are
probably used in that movie that aren't
really used that much these days which
is a shame I think again but um
I think that's the single best movie
that you can use to improve your
Japanese uh for this native exposure so
to speak
again it's a Japanese movie that's
nothing but Japanese speech from start
to finish that is meant for Japanese
people you know not foreigners that are
learning Japanese
I loved that and it's a great movie too
I think it's a wonderful movie so
I would highly recommend it okay uh hey
Logan correct congrats on 500k Korean
patch I've been trying to do something
similar uh uh do similar work to you but
with Korean thanks for all the
inspiration come hang out and uh Busan
sometime hey thank you very much I'd
love to go I lived in Korea for like
three months in between when I was doing
the jet program and when I started
teaching English in so I really
appreciate it if I'm ever there yeah
I'll reach out appreciate the offer and
again of course thank you very much for
the super chat
um
okay let's keep going uh what's up dog
and happy 500k I reacted to a video and
nitpicked somebody's Japanese info wanna
nitpick mine and feed into the infinite
con content Loop
um so
you are a Japanese native or you are an
English
native I reacted to a video and
nitpicked someone's Japanese info you
you nitpicked their Japanese want to
nitpick mine and feed into the infinite
content Loop ah look at these Bots these
Bots are getting out of control
um
what do I say put user and timeout uh uh
hide user on this channel
okay I think that fixed it
um
sorry I'm not entirely sure what you're
saying but I've done a fair number of
reaction videos like I did a
reacting to Yuda you thought like
talking about me reacting to
you know I did the joke video that was
you know reacting to Joey and Chris's
Japanese of course like Joey's Japanese
it's impossible to react to it because
it's literally perfect it's better than
most native Japanese and I think it's I
think it's stupid to also like you know
seriously react to Chris's Japanese
either because you know his Japanese is
great to begin with but that's not like
not what he's known for so you know it's
weird to find it's weird to an idea yeah
Metatron as well that's right
like um
I really should have been reacting to
like I don't know like Chris is like
directorial style or whatever what he's
really known for making these really
great you know videos so of course
what I tried to do is just make the
whole thing a comedy and really just
make fun of myself more than anything
else and
I think that video turned out pretty
well I like that one
um
I like to think so
okay uh hey delgan been watching you for
years congrats on 500k is there any
media you would recommend for beginner
slash intermediate level Japanese
um yeah I'm gonna type this in again
it's an older movie but it's the best
movie you can watch if you're a beginner
or intermediate level that's the level
that I was at when I started watching
that um
when I was sort of watching that movie
and it was funny because
through listening to it so many times I
started to just understand it despite
the fact that I wasn't like
um what would you say actively like
looking up all the words in the movie
there were points that that I I was but
it was it was funny because like there'd
be like a long sentence and I would I
wouldn't understand anything that was
said but I had watched the movie so many
times that like
if I looked up just these two words
and even if I didn't understand these
ones
I started to like understand the
sentences because of the context of the
surrounding sentences which I could
understand and so I really think it's
important that you watch the same thing
over and over again if you're trying to
increase
um
comprehension but then also really get a
good understanding of the sounds of
Japanese because I I personally think
that there's a difference between kind
of like telling yourself that you're
studying Japanese and doing like a an
anime binge and kind of like you know
different things are happening happening
in every episode maybe you're not like
um there aren't so many reoccurring
words and in that sense a lot of them
will kind of go into your short-term
memory and then straight out the other
ear so to speak but if you watch the
same thing over and over again you kind
of
ingrain them you get them in your bones
and so I would re I would highly highly
highly recommend watching 12 kind
Japanese people on repeat that's what I
did and it worked really really well for
me okay
um
okay
calm dog you inspired me to keep
learning Japanese keep up the good work
very happy to hear that thank you very
much for the Super Chat and good luck
with your future studies Antoine band I
can't make this bigger but thank you
very much for the Super Chat wow 20
bucks very much appreciated thank you so
much man
oh Banda Ben bandel oh YouTuber
um here's a digital trophy for you thank
you very much
appreciate it thank you so much yeah 12
Angry Men but Japanese version yeah it's
kind of like it's yeah the Japanese
version of 12 Angry Men but it's
it had it's a little bit more comedic so
yeah
um
okay why is it so difficult to find
Japanese subtitles for Japanese movies
is it I think if you actually like buy
the DVD or like buy the film on like
Amazon or you know like iTunes or
whatever usually they have the bandelay
okay sorry about that and thank you
again for the uh Super Chat
um
yeah it's a little bit more it has kind
of more of a comedic touch to it than 12
Angry Men that's really just more like a
courtroom drama this is kind of like a
courtroom drama slash comedy
um okay
um
foreign
cyberpunk Edge runners
foreign
foreign
this might be a really controversial
thing to say but I'm like really curious
about this for the people in chat that
have seen both
Cowboy Bebop
the original series
and
cyberpunk Edge Runners I'm really
curious what people think is the better
of the two
um and personally
um
I think I personally prefer cyberpunk
Edge runners
okay
Cowboy Bebop for the win interesting
PreCure
pull time uh can you do polls
I don't know how to do that
um anyway
um when practicing Converse conversing
with people in Japan is there any sign
slash body language to pick up on to
indicate that they don't want to or uh
or are uncomfortable with trying to
converse
um
there are a lot but I think that if
you're
there are almost
so many that you can't even like it
would be impossible for me to explain
and what I mean by that is like that's
like the Japanese language like that's
like the entire language like you can
listen to like a five minute
conversation where someone is like doing
nothing but praise the the person that
they're talking about or like oh yeah
like I got you like a gift like it's
like this really like cheap thing like
it's really stupid I know you won't like
it but I just you know I that I saw and
I thought you might like it's you know
not a big please will you take it you
know and that's kind of
but that's just like that's just the
Japanese way of saying here I found
something for you I got a present for
you you just have to kind of do things
in Japanese and a much more roundabout
way and that's true for kind of like
Japanese body language as well
um I don't know maybe like looking at
the ground a lot or checking their watch
a lot or on their phone a lot you know
like the really obvious things of course
but um
yeah
there's almost too many to count
um
what why compare those two
LMAO it's because
I don't want to get into this because
this is going to like get me canceled
but
um
so many people absolutely love Cowboy
Bebop and I think that Cowboy Bebop is a
landmark of anime but
to me
it really felt like there were like
three or four episodes in that series
that were
you could have like kind of thrown out
and it wouldn't have affected the series
at all
and I'm much more
of a fan of Series where every single
episode plays into the story and so in
that sense I've always preferred
um like my favorite anime of all time is
monster
and like one thing I really really loved
about cyberpunk Edge Runners is how
again like it felt like every single
episode was progressing the story and
again like I think in terms of music
Atmosphere characters dialogue action
sequences all around
um Cowboy Bebop is certainly certainly a
masterpiece but I've never really heard
people
talk about I don't know maybe it's just
my perception of the series but they're
like again like two or three or maybe
four uh maybe even more than that
episodes in that Series where it felt
like
this isn't really progressing the story
at all and there were times when I was
watching that I I essentially
um binged watched Cowboy Bebop and there
were some episodes especially the
earlier episodes when
um the protagonist is in the church with
and he has the gun fight and Faye is uh
you know tied up on like one of the on
one of the pillars in church and like he
gets like knocked out of the window and
like that entire like
the series up until that point I was
absolutely captivated I was like this is
such an incredible like unbelievably
good anime like I totally get why people
are
so so into it but then
it kept on going and then again there
were like three or four episodes where I
found myself
like waiting for something new to happen
in the story but it it wouldn't they
would kind of like go somewhere and do
something that wasn't really related to
anything
like to the main characters like
backstory or to like their objectives in
the future and stuff like that and I
found myself kind of like waiting like
when are we going to get back to the to
the main thing and in that sense because
they're both kind of kind of set and I
don't know if Cowboy Bebop is really
like cyberpunk it's you know kind of
more just like I don't know sci-fi
Adventure so to speak but
um I don't know does anyone think that
about Convoy be evolved am I the only
one that thinks that
am I gonna get canceled for this opinion
okay
um sorry let me let me get these super
chats okay uh hey Doug congrats on the
Milestone it's much deserved I've been
looking to to deepen my Japanese subject
knowledge like math and science what
resources are available online slash uh
available abroad you've been a huge
inspiration
um to Japan to deepen your Japanese
subject knowledge like math and science
you know to be honest I would just say
get like get like an elementary school
textbook or like if your level's high
enough like a middle school textbook for
math or science or actually uh YouTube
um he's got a really cool video
a really good video that talks about
um
I cannot remember the name he talks
about
there's like this theorem in math that
like it wasn't solved for like 300 years
um and then recently like in the last
like 20 or 30 years like there was this
uh mathematician that kind of like
finally finally solved it and he talks
about that whole story in Japanese and
it's really really interesting
um but uh
he he sometimes covers topics that are
related to he's a YouTuber really good
YouTuber in my opinion
um and help break down topics like I
don't know cryptocurrency or like you
know
um the metaverse or you know things that
you could construe you could you could
not construe you could say that there
you could argue that they're in the
science field
um like uh
blockchain and that kind of thing he
sometimes again talks about like famous
mathematicians and that kind of thing
and uh that might be a good way for you
to study again
no YouTube okay the Japanese in the
movie isn't quite uh natural not even as
exaggerated as in the anime but it's
basically the same in English
um if you're talking about the movie
that I recommended earlier
it's very natural Japanese it's not
exaggerated like an anime
okay uh so does anyone else think this
is about Cowboy Bebop okay uh
true
like Filler episodes I do agree on that
yeah that's fair that makes sense one
piece is not for you uh correct Bebop is
an anthology like Star Trek or buster
uh Scruggs
yeah like
is that the correct way to watch Cowboy
Bebop in this sense it's like it's more
like something like Star Trek where it's
like you've got the same crew that's got
like a really interesting backstory and
kind of like the they have these
um you know different Adventures that
they they sometimes go on and then
there's kind of like also an underlying
story that uh happens as well I just I
that's always been the one thing the
only thing that slightly bugged me about
Cowboy Bebop is again there was a couple
episodes that felt to me like they were
just throw away like they went somewhere
they got like a new job or something and
then they went and they did this thing
and then they came back and it was like
the entire thing that happened in that
episode was completed in that episode by
itself and it wasn't related to what had
happened before and what was going to
happen later in terms of the the total
story and
again in that sense I personally felt
like there was a little bit of downtime
I was I was waiting for the next big
import not necessarily big thing but I
was waiting for the narration to
progress
um and that's why I really love series
like you know like Edge runners or or
Monster or I think another good one
Kyojin I think is a really good example
as well like every single episode
progresses the story
and
um
yeah well there's a place for chill
episodes though uh musishi is one of
those with tones of that I personally
enjoy relaxing to those before sleeping
yeah I mean like again I I still thought
it was really enjoyable I just
personally I think I I would have
enjoyed it a little bit more if um they
had like those two or three episodes
maybe it was like four not sure but
there was a there was a few
um it's all episodic because they're all
different folk tales
yeah I guess that that's one way to to
look at it anyway I've kind of given my
spiel
on that so let's let's move on to the
next topic before I get canceled again
uh okay let's keep going
so you're saying what was this
uh the Cowboy Bebop is cyber nor uh near
future okay
how did you find a place to Homestay in
Tokyo I did it through my University
uh cyberpunk is related genre uh about
burning out Young
I didn't know that that was like a what
would you say not Trope but like theme
of the genre
um
Dogan is my favorite flesh Trooper
okay oh Thomas wow well Jesus is that a
hundred dollars that's crazy oh my God
hey Logan congrats on 500k can't believe
I've been subscribed to you to your
channel and patreon for literal years
now please continue making more videos
with the Tomas characters so I can keep
feeling called out thanks yeah it was it
was funny when I made that video the one
that you're talking about
um R.I.P Thomas the exchange student the
funny thing about that is that I
realized when I made that video when I
was scripting it that I never explored
that Dynamic of like I I regularly do
the conversations between like a um
like a Japanese person and a foreigner
like you know they're both like I don't
know college students or something like
that or they both like working like a
Japanese company or like they're just
friends and like they're out like uh
together at like a family outing or
something but
I was like I've never made a video where
it was like
the the setting was the study abroad
student and in the Homestay family and
the two like not really being able to
talk to each other because the study
abroad students uh his Japanese wasn't
good enough so I thought that it would
make for you know decent video
but I'll I'll keep making more thank you
very much for the Super Chat and again
thank you for your support over the
years on patreon as well and or castra
Jesus a hundred dollars oh my God all
right
behold in akasupa
for defeating my own sen dreams kick
already
that's crazy thank you so much really
really appreciate that okay Dogan do you
still offer Japanese lessons um yeah so
this might be a good time to talk about
it but uh for those that don't know I
teach Japanese I think most people know
this but I teach Japanese pronunciation
and Pitch Accent on my patreon I'll
leave a link in the chat right now
um
kind of like uh what would you say
there are many elements of Japanese that
are not taught in the classroom and I
strongly believe that if you don't study
them you'll develop
habits arguably bad habits that can be
very very difficult
to fix and I think that for
pronunciation it's not necessarily like
a really big deal but I think it is a
big deal for pitch accent because pitch
accent is typically never taught in the
classroom and I think that if you learn
pitch accent at least a little bit it'll
make a very very very big difference in
your Japanese and so I teach Japanese
pitch accent again on my patreon in
video form I've got an entire series
that's broken down I break down all the
concepts of Japanese pitch accent in
easy to understand English with at least
for the overwhelming majority of the
lessons in
um
using high quality native Japanese
recordings from someone that went to the
NHK Academy and we're continuing to
update the lessons that um have not yet
been updated with the native recordings
I think there's like maybe
I don't know like between there's like
85 or something like lessons in the in
the series total if you count everything
and uh I think there's like maybe like
20 or so that have yet to be updated but
those are all of the the much much more
advanced topics and so again if you're
if you want to sound as natural as
possible I personally recommend signing
up for my patreon series there's a lot
to learn about Japanese paychecks and if
you've never studied it before but the
other announcement that I want to make I
think again most people know that I
teach on patreon is that in the
relatively near future in less than a
month we're going to be starting doing
private pitch accent lessons we found a
native
uh we found a native speaker that is
also trained and used to be a former um
newscaster in Japan and she reached out
and said hey I'm trying to teach a pitch
accent can we try and maybe do something
together where you connect me with
students that want to do one-on-one
lessons and so in the very near future
we're setting things up right now
um she's going to be doing she's going
to be doing one-on-one lessons and maybe
in the future group lessons as well for
the people that have gone through the
series and are going through the series
but then also want direct feedback
because what I have is it's a video
series so you kind of watch it at your
own pace and you learn the concepts and
you do like the listening drills and you
do shadowing and stuff like that but
um I don't personally critique the
Japanese of all the people that are in
my course and because of that the course
itself is is quite cheap it's like ten
dollars a month so it's very very
affordable but for the people that do
want that personal feedback we're going
to be offering that in the very near
future so I would encourage you to again
sign up on patreon if you're if you want
to be one of the first people that would
get access to that and I'll I'll leave
the link down here one more time for
anyone that's interested okay
that's the that's the Shameless plug
okay uh Orchestra again
not to interrupt your excellent teaching
but what do you call a pod of musical
whales hmm
I don't know is this is some kind of
joke that's like flying over my head
right now
uh
is it a is it a pod
uh on time in time uh
uh made it
call you by deutsdale
uh I made it
uh he just said Orchestra or castra
um yeah there's a joke there that I'm
not saying sorry
okay speaking of NHK learn Japanese from
the news is an outstanding short show on
NHK world to listen to polite NHK
Japanese
uh LMAO the answer is in plain sight
um
work straw
that's uh
that's rough
but appreciate it
hmm
Orca the whale right got it got it
what do you call a pot of musical whales
orc straw
got it
nailed it
sorry I'm a little bit behind on my uh
english comprehension I'm a little bit
slow so okay uh game therapy that sounds
like a YouTube channel cool um Dogan how
would you go about approaching kanji
I've so far learned about 100 kanji over
the years but I lack the right approach
everyone says sit down and keep writing
it
um so actually fundamentally
have it um I don't I don't this uh I
think there's a better approach and I
think that the better approach is just
to use an Anki app like a
so uh what do you say SRS app it's like
one of these flash card apps
that you use to memorize not individual
individual kanji but words so like
rather than
remembering the kanji for like
like I'm going to type a Word in chat
right now psycho this means the best in
Japanese like the highest the best
rather than using like an app to
remember PSY and then also later on
remember the word or the kanzi for Cole
and then remember all their various
different readings I personally think
it's best to memorize individual words
so just remember the word cycle
and in doing that
when you learn a lot of words you start
to slowly but surely
through osmosis also learn the various
readings of kanji a kanji so in in that
sense I think that you can get a lot
more bang for your buck if you're just
trying to memorize words because
if you're if you're trying to memorize
words and kanji then you have to split
the time between the two right but if
you memorize just words you'll memorize
the kanji a little bit slower but you
you will memorize them if you keep going
and at the same time you'll learn way
more words and usually that's that's the
better way to go if you're early on in
your Japanese studies but I never ever
ever did like the sit down and just
write kanji over and over again approach
and I don't think mycology is that that
good in that sense like there's a lot of
kanji I still have difficulty in reading
but my buddy Matt versus Japan can read
Japanese better than basically anyone
that I know and he took the exact same
approach that I did he he doesn't
recommend well he did the same thing
that I did and he also recommends what I
just said you know like memorize words
rather than kanji and you'll you'll pick
up the kanji through osmosis and the
thing with kanji is that
um
it's also kind of a waste of time to
learn how to write them because
there are so few opportunities to
actually write kanji these days in
Japanese Society like most Japanese
people have to take out their smartphone
even to write basic Japanese kanji and
so nine times out of ten you're you're
gonna be fine just being able to read it
hey what's up Sora Sora the troll big
fan I started learning Japanese because
I've met your channel a while ago keep
up the great work dog and Sensei
Sora thank you very much I'm I'm also a
big fan I uh I really liked the um the
what would you say analysis video that
you did with like a Floyd
the Floyd May uh Meriwether May weather
Mayweather you know that whole situation
that was a really funny well done video
I really liked that and I don't know if
I can talk about it here but um Sora and
I have done some stuff in the past and
we're going to be doing stuff again in
the future for those that don't know he
kind of does like the same thing that I
do but the opposite so I'm a foreigner
that makes like comedic content in
Japanese and Sora
is a Japanese dude that makes comedic
content usually in English but he also
sometimes is sometimes uses Japanese as
well kind of in the same way that like
I'll mix in like English and some of my
skits as well but awesome Channel really
good troll
and yeah we we're gonna collab sometime
okay I wonder who is the real you the
bitter Dogan in your videos or the nice
Dogan on the stream
um well this is this is the real me but
um
I don't think the real me is very
interesting like I'm I don't know just
like a dude or whatever but I think like
most people
um through writing I'm able to create
something that actually is interesting
hopefully
um
[Music]
yeah yeah yeah yeah isn't Meriwether the
security company from GTA I was thinking
like I watched The Hobbit recently and I
was thinking about him
or I don't know I could be getting
confused but guys I gotta go in about uh
two minutes so if anyone has any
questions uh or anything they want to
say in the end I would encourage you to
this is the kind of the last chance I
gotta get going
um
foreign
foreign
foreign
foreign
foreign
[Music]
do you recommend a particular way to
revise already learned Japanese revise
already learned Japanese I'm not sure
what you mean by that I apologize for
that
yeah no teachers can correct our accents
content
foreign
I gotta get going guys but uh
um
what's your favorite Japanese author and
his book my favorite Japanese author is
she and my favorite book of hers is
it's a collection of short stories okay
guys I gotta get going but thanks so
much for the stream this was incredible
I can't I can't believe we're finally at
500k so it took long enough I want to
say again thank you to everyone for all
your support over the years and we're
gonna have a couple of
uh announcements on the channel in the
near future that uh
uh I would say be hopefully some people
will enjoy so I gotta get going guys but
uh thank you all for your support over
the years and I'll see you again soon
okay guys see you later bye bye
later guys